I never was that sad do you remember  that Simone biles has made her love for  Zac Efron no secret and a 28 year old  grooved he's a fan of hers too  when he travelled to Rio to meet the  Olympic star this week but Simone's pal  who she dubbed her a Brazilian boyfriend  on Instagram is staking his claim arthur  nori a member of the brazilian  gymnastics team had a little fun on  instagram he reposted this shot of him  and Simone and sent a clear message hey  Zac Ephron  I saw her first she is my girl proud of  you Simone you are phenomenal in whole  world and special you made history love  you still we're giving Zack extra points  for making the trip to Brazil  their story just blew my mind and when I  find out Simone and the team was a fan I  was like what kind of guy am i if I  don't show